the Joe Rogan experience would what what
will possess someone to want that job I
mean look if you wanted to have the the
best-case-scenario answer it's like I
want to do a good job and make this
country great and do better and but what
do you think really it's ego I was
watching Andrew yang on some morning
talk show on Sunday and he's he's
walking down the street with his wife
and it's a Sunday he's got his [ __ ]
kids and I'm like this is your Sunday
he's got followers with his name on as
much like strangers with Fitzsimmons on
a placard walking behind you cheering on
a Sunday want to be home I don't watch a
[ __ ] football game play with my kid
make a meal but these people every day
they're working 16-hour days where
they're speaking saying the same [ __ ]
and they're saying we're we're winning
it they always say we know just say I am
be as [ __ ] selfish as you really are
I'm waiting more people are liking me
than those other people hmm it's a bad
job it's a bad job that no one should
have it's a job that should be a giant
round table of geniuses should be
deciding the fate of the country yeah
and they all should be on mushrooms
they all should be on ego dissolved in
doses of mushrooms so that none of them
are acting in their own self-interest
they all should have zero financial
investments in anything that has
anything to do with any decisions that
they make like they should have to give
up all their stocks they should have to
absolutely make sure like like Trump is
able to have all his businesses be run
by his kids which is kind of hilarious
yeah but then he makes decisions that
would benefit his businesses that are
being run by his kids and the sooner
he's out of office he get she jumps back
in and takes over again was just like
yeah it's what do you thinks gonna
happen when they get his taxes cuz
they're pretty close they're pretty
clear it's gonna go to the Supreme Court
now the the last Court said that he has
to turn them over and what they're doing
is they're going after his accountant
instead of him that way the accountant
will be liable as opposed to him
personally because he's never gonna do
it but if you're if you're
[ __ ] you know Harvey Altman yeah in
company yeah you have to you got to do
it you're not gonna go to jail for him
right you sewed up with Michael Cohen
right you go to jail yeah yeah
there's no pardons you're going to jail
bunch of went to jail yeah quite a few
people in jail man afford Janet for jail
real jail yeah like like you can't see
anybody locked in a cell jail it's not
gonna matter when his taxes come out
it's not gonna matter it's nothing none
of it matters he's got his file the only
thing this election comes down to is
whether or not the left can get people
to show up because his 46% or whatever
percent are into him they're [ __ ]
there on November fourth next year
they're showing up you know it was crazy
Chris Rock went on stage right after he
won and Chris Rock said you don't know
that [ __ ] he goes let me tell
you something he ain't leaving he goes
he's gonna be the president for a long
[ __ ] time
he ain't gonna leave mm and I was
thinking like what does that mean like
you have to leave yeah like if he loses
you imagine if he loses and he doesn't
want he doesn't believe he lost well
he's already said he won't believe it
he's already said that she was gonna be
a revolution he's yeah he's you know
he's laying the groundwork for could
could be ugly including it the
impeachment which would be even worse
than him just not getting elected if he
was impeached can you imagine what would
happen I don't think he's going to get
not impeached if he was he's being
impeached yeah if he was convicted it
was if he's convicted and removed from
office it would be crazy yeah but I
don't think that's gonna happen
I think someone explained to me was a
Kyle Dunnigan explain to me how many
people what's up no no sorry Kyle Kyle
kolinsky who's my favorite online
political commentator very wise guys
left-wing guy but like he calls it like
he sees it he's very educated and very
aware of all the pitfalls that that is
plaguing the left and the right and he
said that you would need all these
Republicans to vote on it in order for
him to
they'd be impeached and they're not
going to they're no they're just like
twenty two Republican senators that
would have to flip yeah then so far they
have zero they're not gonna flip now the
nerves are not there they're more
interested in their party than they are
in anything else
[Applause]